[Music]
there's a tremendous amount of will uh
in the American population particularly
uh to uh to explore um uh the United
States you know maybe more than any
other country um is a distillation of
the human Spirit of exploration um and
it's really fundamental to psyche so if
people think there's a way I think it
actually get a lot of support um but but
they it it can't be just banging your
head against the wall I got to believe
that this can be done without breaking
the federal budget um so that's when I
said okay well is there some way to
affect the cost of space transport and
um and is and
so I got together with a group of people
over a series of Saturdays just to just
try understand is there something super
fundamentally super expensive about
Rockets or or can the cost be
substantially improved um and um we had
a bunch of those kind of brainstorming
sessions and I couldn't see I couldn't
see any fundamental obstacle to
improving the cost of rockets
so that's when I started
[Music]
SpaceX